Hello. It's Dessert Week.
I wonder where Matt is.
Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off!
Hey, Cherry Bakewell, you haven't
seen Matt Lucas, have you?
No, I haven't seen him.
Well, if you do, can you tell him
I'm looking for him? Yeah, OK.
I love you a little bit.
I don't mind you.
Last time...
This one doesn't play
to my strengths.
...the heat was on as the
bakers tackled ice cream.
I need to work quite fast
before it melts.
Hermine kept her cool...
You're doing classical
things beautifully.
...to win Star Baker
for the first time.
Congratulations.
Cherry on the icing.
...while a silly mistake...
Didn't press the ice setting.
...threatened Laura's place
in the competition.
It just went from bad to worse.
Pretty embarrassed about this one.
But it was Lottie who
had a meltdown...
It's game over.
...and had to say goodbye.
Lottie. Just give me a minute.
Now, the quarterfinal...
Oh! Help, help, help, help.
...and it's all about desserts.
Jeepers creepers.
That's... not awful.
They're not set. Great.
The bakers hope Cheesecakes...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
...don't leave them
feeling cheesed off.
They're sinking back in on
themselves.
That's slightly concerning.
They have to elevate jelly...
Wow, that's tremendous.
...to new heights of
baking artistry...
I think it is completely beautiful.
...and they're taken back
to the 17th century...
Oh, got a leaky situation.
...in an old-school suet
and citrus technical.
I... am... having... a...
...suet...break...down.
One step away from...
MIMICS "PSYCHO" THEME
TOGETHER: One, two, three -
quarterfinals!
Here we go!
I didn't think I would
make it to this week
and I was telling the other bakers,
I left a few eggs in my fridge,
thinking, "I'll come back to those."
Well, they won't be
good now, will they?
Quarterfinals.
That's cool, innit? Yeah.
All my family are super proud of me,
that I've managed to get this far.
Yeah, madness, isn't it?
Suddenly, you realise there is a
possibility I could be in the final,
and that's a little bit scary.
This week is kind of nerve-racking.
There's been some practice
that hasn't gone so well.
So I think it's the week that
I'm most unsure about so far.
Hello, bakers.
Today, the judges would love
you to make 12 identical...
...baked mini Cheesecakes.
Mini ones? I know. Oh...
Your disappointingly
small Cheesecakes
should have a baked filling.
Your virtually invisible Cheesecakes
should have a base that
is made from scratch.
Hardly worth it.
You have two-and-a-half hours.
On your marks...
..get set... bake!
LAURA: I think it's only my mum
that doesn't like Cheesecakes.
So, I don't eat many Cheesecakes.
I have an aversion to
cheese in general.
I've made a New York-style
cheesecake,
but that did have that massive
Grand Canyon crack down it.
It's the quarterfinals,
and, actually, this is where
the bakers really do have to
take it up a couple of notches.
I want the cheesecake filling to be
full of flavour but silky smooth.
For the base, I'd like to have a
little bit more texture to it.
Just stirring some oats in a pan,
making a lovely oat-y crumble.
PRUE: The top should
be very decorative
and it must be good flavour,
cos you're only getting a tiny one,
you want a punch.
Got to do a lot of
multitasking today.
We're asking for 12 of them,
and they are to be very exquisite.
It has to look absolutely beautiful.
We've got five bakers remaining
and all of them are
star bakers this year.
It's the first time it's happened,
so I'm expecting some sublime bakes.
What could go wrong?
Gosh. Can't see a thing
out of those.
Good morning, Peter.
Good morning. Peter. Hello.
Cheesecakes. Yes.
What have you decided to do?
I'm making ginger
and lime Cheesecakes.
So it's Key lime pie-esque.
Key lime pie vibes, yeah.
That's pretty much what I would've
chosen to do. Oh, that's good.
You've just got to do it right, now.
Peter's tiny take on one of
Paul's favourite desserts
will see baked lime Cheesecakes on
an oat and gingernut biscuit base,
delicately decorated
with crystallised ginger
and dots of lime curd.
This is the first baked one
that I've ever made.
I think I made a couple of
set ones at school, I think,
in Home Ec, maybe.
Baby-faced disaster, come on.
If you're not in the final
I'll be disappointed.
Just making a traditional
digestive base.
All great Cheesecakes start
with a delicious biscuit.
I never made the biscuits
for my cheesecake before.
I don't know who does that, but...
...it's a challenge!
Right, what's next?
Oh, BLEEP.
Good job I made more, isn't it?
Whoopsie.
Laura's honey and oat biscuit
will form the base of her vanilla
and passion fruit cheesecakes.
With a topping of firm-set
passion fruit curd,
she's hoping to avoid a repeat
of last week's meltdown.
I've been having nightmares
about that ice cream cake,
to be honest with you. So have I!
Like, loads!
I don't wanna make
any more mistakes now.
Just focus now, that's it. Yeah.
That's the plan. All right.
Good luck. Thank you.
NOEL: While everyone's biscuits
will be flavoured differently...
I'm getting the pulp out of
the passion fruit.
...there's a common theme emerging
to the bit that goes on top.
So I've just added in
passion fruit extract,
and it just gives it a
bit more va-va-voom.
We're all doing our own
interpretation of passion fruit.
Morning, Dave. Good morning.
Hello, David.
Tell us about your mini Cheesecakes.
I'm calling it a citrus cheesecake.
The filling will be a traditional,
like, lemon cheesecake filling,
and then on the top there will be
a passion fruit and orange glaze.
Dave's adding orange juice and zest
to his shortbread biscuit,
topping each cheesecake
with lime kisses
and setting his passion fruit
and orange glaze with gelatine.
That's quite a lot of gelatine.
I found because of the citrus-ness
of the orange and passion fruit,
it sometimes doesn't set properly.
So rather than cutting down the
citrus you just add more gelatine.
Yeah. Do you know what?
I'm playing golf later.
Maybe I could use one of
your Cheesecakes.
Cheesecake should offer a
mouth-watering blend
of contrasting textures.
A nice crunch at the bottom.
Nice soft filling and hopefully a
nice easy cut-able glaze on the top.
Everyone's using moulds to support
these layers during baking...
You need a bit of structure there to
support the cheesy, creamy filling.
...and reigning Star Baker Hermine
is making her mould
part of her presentation.
I like anything to do with jars.
I make my own jam at home.
I quite like to decorate
them cutely.
Hermine's hoping her mini jam jars
will produce perfect
Cheesecakes as well.
Her combination of a
cinnamon biscuit base
and a curd decorated with
meringue kisses and lime zest
will also be the third signature
flavoured with passion fruit.
Oh.
There's battle of the passion fruit
in the tent, it seems.
I don't really like passion fruit.
No? No. I've sort of gone off it.
Really? He's lying.
Don't worry, Hermine, he loves it.
So you'll leave them in
the jar, then, will you?
I will leave them in the jar.
OK, that's interesting.
So, it should be wonderful. Good.
Thank you, Hermine. Thank you!
Good luck. Thanks!
NOEL: Bakers, you
are halfway through.
Oh, that's not good.
Matthew. Yes? I'd like you to meet
one of my friends. Ooh, yes, please.
Couple of series ago... Yes.
...there was a guy called
Mr Spoon that was here...
Oh, yeah, I loved him!
..and he went missing.
Do you remember him? Yeah, I do!
Well, this is his cousin. Oh, hello!
Would you like to touch him?
Yes, what's his name?
His name is, er...
...Andre. Andre Spoon. Andre!
HERMINE: Well, I need to
get down to business now.
Just filling up my Cheesecakes
with the topping.
Just trying to get it as even
as possible.
NOEL: How the mini Cheesecakes
have baked...
Bain-marie helps get a better
texture of cheesecake.
I didn't go down the bain-marie
route. Might regret that.
...is critical in determining the
silky smooth filling texture
that Paul and Prue are looking for.
Rinky-dink. We are good to go.
Once in the oven...
Low and slow.
...precision with temperature
and timings is crucial.
Ten minutes and then I reduce
it and another ten minutes.
They're very temperamental
little things.
OK. Get these in.
Mark is the only baker
going citrus-free.
Vanilla cheesecake is my favourite,
and there's kind of nowhere
to hide with it
so I'm just hoping I can pull it off
and make it a good cheesecake.
He's bringing pecans,
apricots and almond
to a vanilla and mascarpone take
on the classic
New York baked cheesecake.
MATT: Why don't we take this show
and put in on Broadway
and turn it into a musical?
A musical!
Do you sing? No. Well, don't
let that stop you. OK.
What's the first number in
Bake Off: The Musical?
SNAPPING FINGERS
# It's over-baked
# It's under- baked
# I'm never happy at all
# Impossible to please
# What a tease
# That's Paul
# That's Paul! #
Bakers, you have half an hour left!
That isn't very long, is it?
How was that?
I don't know what that means.
He's been in a lot of therapy.
Difficult to tell.
There is a pretty fine line
between over and under-baked
on the Cheesecakes.
If you over-bake them,
they're gonna start cracking.
Under-baked and you're gonna get
some weird, eggy mixture
that doesn't set and
is gonna be gross.
They've got a bit of
a clip in the middle.
NOEL: Oh, you could've warned me!
I've inhaled quite a lot of steam.
You just let off some
kettles in my face.
They look all right. Do they?
How can you tell?
Can you put something in them?
Gosh, yeah, they're ready.
Maybe a little bit too much.
MATT: The cooling of the cheesecakes
is another baking balancing act.
Can't trust a cheesecake.
If rushed...
A few cracked.
...there's a risk of
cracking and dipping.
So, they're sinking back in
on themselves quite a lot.
Not exactly the sight that
we were wanting to see.
If cooled too slowly...
I've just turned the oven off
and I'm gonna let them cool down
a little in the oven.
Leave them there long as possible.
..the mini Cheesecakes won't set
in time to support the
toppings and decorations.
And now we watch them.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left!
HERMINE: They've just about set.
Now my passion fruit coulis.
The curd's pretty thin.
That's slightly concerning.
It's quite central
to the decoration.
Do I just melt a tiny bit of
butter and add that in?
Yeah, I'm gonna give that a shot.
I think they're set.
Any longer, I think they're
gonna collapse anyways.
They look very neat. Thank you.
I've got to release them yet.
Gotta release them! Yeah, release
in the air. Fly, my pretties!
Whoa! That's hot.
Turning out time.
No, they're not set.
How long have we got left?
NOEL: Bakers, you only have
five minutes left!
LAURA GROANS
Can you ask Mr Spoon to
get out of my chair please?
He's just relaxing. Yeah, I
just don't trust him. All right!
The curd is not good,
and I shouldn't have added that
butter so I think it's not usable.
Yeah, we're looking for
taste on this, I think.
Mr Spoon didn't like how
that last time call went.
I don't like Mr Spoon.
He wants an apology.
Well, he's not getting one from me.
Do you like him? Love Mr Spoon.
You do? Yeah. He wants to kiss you.
Mr Spoon says he wants
to see Peter naked. OK.
NOEL GIGGLES
Even more reason
to dislike Mr Spoon.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slippery little buggers.
So the gelatine's just about set.
Just hope they turn out well.
Great!
So I've got a bit of
lime syrup in here.
This is baking on the fly,
definitely.
Come on!
It's not gonna be that refined,
I must admit.
They're a little bit squidgy.
The next layer is
the meringue kisses.
Bakers, you have one minute left!
Gosh, one minute to go.
I'm getting the shakes now.
OK, let's just do what we can.
I'm filling them slightly more
than planned
clue to the rather cratering clip
in the middle.
They just didn't set in time.
Rubbish.
Bakers, your time is up.
SHE SIGHS
Please place your mini Cheesecakes
at the end of your work stations.
Think they're actually still warm.
I think they'll taste nice.
MATT: The baked Cheesecakes will now
face the scrutiny of Prue and Paul.
Hi, Dave. Hello.
H I, Dave, right.
I think they look very neat, they
do look very good. Thank you.
Well, they cut neatly, don't they?
The custard middle I
think is absolutely delicious,
and the texture's perfect.
Thank you.
The jelly is surprisingly
thick, and I like it.
I was a bit worried about
the amount of gelatine
you were putting in there.
Yeah. Did you hold back,
or did you put it all in?
I did put it all in, yeah.
I was expecting it to be a little
bit rubbery. OK. And it wasn't...
Yeah... cos it did melt.
But I think you've done a good job.
I think you've ticked all the boxes.
It's neat, and it
tastes good. Thank you.
Cheers. Well done. Thank you. Oh!
They do look really pretty.
They look amazing.
It's a bit stodgy. Mm.
It's not as silky as I'd hoped.
The base is very soft. There's
no way that base could be solid
in the bottom of that because
it's going to sweat in there,
the moisture from the cheesecake
filling will drop in there
and soften it up anyway.
There's not enough lime in there.
Or passion fruit.
It looks good.
Thank you.
They're like canape size. OK.
I would've done it slightly
bigger than the apricot.
That's too big and too thin. Yeah.
You don't get any apricot at
all until you hit the apricot.
You don't really get the
vanilla either. Really? Oh, no.
I just think it needed to be
smaller, packed with more flavour.
Yeah, more vanilla. And just
look much neater. Sure, OK.
And the apricot should've
been everywhere,
cos when you get a bit of apricot
with it, it was truly delicious.
Sure, OK. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
WHISPERS: Well done.
Hmm.
It doesn't look
like a cheesecake. Oh. Um...
The mixture itself
must be quite delicate.
It has formed a little cauldron.
There's your cheesecake there.
Look at the ridge around there.
You've dropped
a lot of height on that.
I think the flavour
is absolutely lovely,
but the shape of it's not perfect.
I'm getting the lime.
The ginger's very light. OK.
It's a nice flavour, but it is lime.
I'm not getting too much
ginger, and it doesn't look
the best thing you've done.
Thank you. Sorry about that.
WHISPERS: Don't
apologise to these people.
So, Laura, just remind us
what's in your Cheesecakes.
It's a vanilla cheesecake
with an oat and honey base,
passion fruit curd and
passion fruit and mango,
what's supposed to be a compote, on
top, but it's a bit of a mudslide.
So sorry. It does
look a bit of a mess.
What I do like is the ratio
to the base and height,
and that's pretty consistent,
however wobbly they are.
I hope you like the taste.
I think they're nice.
Mm.
It's delicious. Yay!
That's fantastic.
The texture's are all there,
from the top, to the
cheesecake, to the base,
which you actually break through.
And the passion fruit's
there, but not overwhelming.
There's absolutely nothing
the matter with this,
except it looks a mess. I'll take
that. Thank you, Laura. Thank you.
Thanks.
Bloody hell.
WHISPERS: Well done. Thank you.
I feel great after that.
I wasn't expecting that,
to be honest,
I was expecting to get rinsed.
Oh...
When Prue and Paul
say "It's delicious,
"and you've got the textures right,"
that is like, yeah, box ticked.
I'm disappointed at that.
Quite a few mistakes in there.
I really did go into
this pretty blind.
It wasn't the best bake,
but we'll have to see.
MATT: For the next challenge,
the bakers face a mystery
wrapped in enigmatic gingham.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Technical Challenge.
And, today, it's been set
for you by the lovely Prue.
Prue, any words of wisdom?
You are all excellent bakers,
so we haven't given you
any extra ingredients.
Get it right the first time.
As ever, the Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have to ask
these two poppets to leave the tent.
Off you go.
THICK ACCENT: Just do it, will you?
This is our park, we play here.
They've got their own park.
Prue has popped back to
the 17005 for this technical.
She would like you each to
make two Sussex pond puddings.
Pond puddings. I'm imagining
frog spawn. Ew.
Your puddings should be
made with suet pastry,
and when steamed, should be golden.
When cut into, the
filling should ooze out,
creating a lemony, syrupy pond.
Mm. Yeah.
You should also serve
a silky smooth creme anglaise.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
I've never heard of
a Sussex pond pudding.
I think my nan would probably
know what it was. Can I call her?
Like probably everyone else,
never seen it before.
I think it's an
encased pastry with...
...it sounds like
a whole lemon inside.
PAUL: So our quarterfinal Technical
Challenge, a Sussex pond pudding.
A particular favourite
of mine, actually.
This is not the prettiest
pudding in the world,
but it's sort of surprising because
there's a whole lemon inside.
Two and a half hours for
this challenge. Mm-hm.
Where do you think
they're going to go wrong?
Suet pastry is not the
easiest pastry to deal with
because it's so pliable, and
if it's too floppy, it will tear.
Squidge. How do they know
when it's going to be ready?
You haven't given
any time, have you?
They should steam it for as
long as they've got, really,
an hour and a half, two hours.
Puddings like this go back
so far in British history.
You know, steamed puddings
is what we were known for.
That sharpness from the lemon,
the sweetness from the sugar
and the butter, rich pastry
that melts in the mouth.
And then you have this gorgeous
creme anglaise, silky smooth,
and that kick of vanilla
as well. It's delicious.
I think it's beautiful.
We've got five great
bakers in that tent.
I can't wait to see what they
come up with, cos this is delicious.
"Make the pastry."
The suet looks like cheese. I mean,
what am I supposed to do with that?
Suet is the lovely
protective fat from animals
that surrounds
the livers, the kidneys.
Yum, yum. Never used suet.
I don't really eat meat.
I mean, does anybody
even eat this in 2020?
I've made, like, suet
dumplings a few times.
Suet dumplings?
Oh, they're good! Really?
Oh, yeah. Lighter than you think.
You can move after six hours.
LAURA: So it just says, "whole
milk", which is really helpful.
They don't even tell you how much
milk you're supposed to add!
This is evil.
So I'm just going to
add it bit by bit
until it comes into
a nice pliable, soft pastry.
Why, why, why would
Prue do this to me?
She's trying to test you. Why?!
HE LAUGHS HEARTILY
You're having a breakdown.
I am having a suet breakdown.
HE LAUGHS
The logical part of me just says
make it like you would
a normal pastry, so don't
overwork it, keep it cold.
So I'm going to let it
rest a little bit.
I have no idea if that's right.
DAVE: So I've made
suet pastry before,
you need to knead it
until really smooth.
I'm also kneading.
Following blindly.
"Prepare and line
the pudding moulds,"
which I've interpreted as
butter and lined with flour,
cos on the ingredients,
it says self-raising flour
plus extra for dusting.
I've greased the sides,
and I'm putting a baking
parchment circle at the bottom.
Which is a bit tricky, cos
you've got a tapered bowl,
but you don't want it
to increase in there,
you want a nice, smooth pudding.
What went through your mind when you
heard you've got to make a Sussex...
EMPHASISES Ps: ..pond pudding?
A little bit of panic.
EMPHASISES Ps: You panicked about
making the pond pudding?
EMPHASISES Ps: Is that what
ha-ppened?
Is it? That's what
happened, yeah. Fair enough.
PETER: "Step three, line
the pudding moulds with pastry,
"reserving some for the lids."
It's not very even, is it?
And they want precision.
We'll do that one again.
So now I've got to make the filling.
"Mix butter and sugar together."
PETER: It's like the most
unhealthy dessert imaginable.
Fatty, "suety" pastry
and then a filling
of butter and sugar.
I mean, it's going to
taste good, isn't it?
Place some in the base
of the pudding moulds.
It feels like it might be
quite heavy in a medieval way.
Yes, definitely very medieval.
"Prick the lemons and place
them in the pastry lined moul
How much pricking
am I supposed to do?
I think a lot of pricks.
LAURA: I don't really fancy a whole
lemon in a bit of pastry, do you?
Sorry, Prue, but that's not
how we do it in Gravesend.
And then it says, "Cover with
the remaining butter and sugar."
One for you, one for me.
One other for you,
and one for me, there you go.
We're all done.
DAVE: "Top the pastry
with lids and seal."
Put a bit of milk on just to try
and get it to stick a bit better
to the top.
All right, so we crimp
or do we not crimp?
Is he crimping?
I'm just trying to
crimp the, oh, dang it.
I'm kind of messing it up
a little bit, to be honest.
It doesn't say to crimp it
but Paul loves a crimp, doesn't he?
Don't know if it will look nice but
I was sort of thinking of pressing
it down slightly with a fork,
like you do with a pie.
"Cut two circles of paper
"and two circles of foil larger
than the top of the pudding moulds."
That's not quite a circle, is it?
The only thing I'm confused
about is the next step now,
where it says, "Fold a pleat
into the centre, then cover."
I don't understand
this pleat business.
NOEL: It's quite minimal, I've seen
the instructions. Very minimal.
Just words, aren't they? Just
words. "Go, do, now, thanks."
"Prue... not... worth...
..the... calories"
What's everyone doing?
Oh, the pleat.
Just crimp and done.
Yeah, so it's that, so that when
the steam rises, it goes like that.
There's room for it to expand.
I forgot that.
"Cover the pudding mould with
the pleated paper and foil
"and secure with string,
looping it first around the rim,
"then across the top
to make a handle."
The string needs to hold
the foil tightly in place
to prevent moisture getting into
the pastry, making it soggy.
Marc's clone a lot of climbing
so he's going to be good
with these knots.
Could even go for a figure of eight.
Damn it.
MATT: I feel a bit un-gentlemanly
not offering to help
but I think it wouldn't be
in the spirit of the competition.
Yeah, can you cross your fingers?
There we go, it's on...
It worked... I think.
Wait, actually, wait. Wait,
now I've got to uncross.
No, no. I can't, because...
Cross them again.
Cross them, keep both
of them crossed. OK.
There we go.
It just pushes off.
Bakers, you are halfway
through your pond puddings!
It says make a handle. I'm
just going to do it my way.
"Place the moulds in
the steamer and steam."
How long are you going to steam for?
An hour?
Don't ask me.
Probably about
an hour 50 in the end.
Did you ever have dim sum?
They steam those,
don't they, sometimes?
Are they nice? Well, I
like dim SUM of them. Nice.
How long did that one take you?
Yeah, it took me...
Well, we workshopped it,
then I decided not to use it.
So, the only thing left to do
is to make a creme anglaise.
NOEL: Creme anglaise is
a combination of egg yolks
and sugar beaten together,
tempered with warm cream and milk,
and delicately
flavoured with vanilla.
Prue said that we are
not able to do it again,
so if we mess up, like, that's it.
It says half a vanilla pod,
and I put up full
vanilla pod in there.
Let's remove a little bit.
SHE CHUCKLES
I'll add in my egg yolk
and sugar mixture slowly.
Otherwise, you're going
to end up with scrambled eggs.
MATT: While the rest of the bakers
are making their creme anglaise,
Dave hasn't even started steaming.
I've got to try and
get this knot in it.
I think it's ready
cos it's thickened.
That one's not so great.
That's the custard done.
All clone. Whether it's good
or not, we shall find out.
Is everyone else finished
apart from me?
Yeah.
All the bakers can do now is wait.
HE EXHALES HEAVILY
What can we do? Surely
there's something we can do.
We could do something
with string, couldn't we?
We could tie up Peter
and ruin his bake.
Bakers, you have half
an hour left, half an hour!
Not that you seem that bothered,
you're all just sitting about.
PETER: Let's see what it looks like.
So I'm looking for it to be
a little bit more brown
and a little bit, sort of, crispier.
Just going to
neglect the string now.
That's going to be fine.
MATT: Last to go in...
Gosh.
..Dave is first to come out.
So, the last thing to do
is turn out and serve.
Ooh.
There you go, some pond puddings.
Oh, disgusting.
Bakers, you have five
minutes left, five minutes!
I'm going to take
out my pond puddings.
MARC: Well, I think it's looking OK.
Lovely soggy suet.
It's a wet pond in the middle,
so not much structure to it.
I'm going to turn mine now, I think.
Well, well.
It's a pond pudding.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Let's try another way
of un-molding it.
Oh...
Got a leakage situation.
Pre-cut it already for them.
It has collapsed.
That's a shame, but it
looks rather impressive.
This one sunk a bit. I did my best.
NOEL: OK, bakers, your time is up.
There's a pond, there's a pudding.
MATT: If you'd like to
bring your puddings
and place them behind
your photographs, please.
The bakers' Sussex pond puddings
now face
the exacting judgment
of Prue and Paul.
Right, bakers,
we were asking for some
well-steamed suet pastry pudding
filled with a whole lemon
and a butter and sugar filling
and some silky creme anglaise.
So, what have we got?
Let's start with this one.
Well, it's leaking already.
They are whole and you can see
the shape, which is a good thing.
The pastry would've been really good
if it had had a little
longer in the steamer,
because you can see
it's beginning to flake.
That's a bit thin, that sauce.
The taste of everything is OK,
it just needed cooking out
a little bit more. Yeah.
Now these, um, pasties.
That's raw.
Well, that looks like
a good custard. Yeah.
Nice and "vanilla-y".
It's nice, that needed sealing
and longer in the steamer.
Now we have one which needed longer.
But at least it's shaped
nicely. Yeah. Absolutely, yeah.
This one is a little more cooked,
but it's still not enough.
That lemon is bullet hard.
The creme anglaise
is all right. Mm-hm.
It's a shame. Yeah, it is
a shame. Now, this one...
I'm not quite sure
what happened here
whether it's just collapsed
in on itself. Yeah, it has.
It's just raw. It is.
In another hour, that pastry
would've been flaky and lovely. Mm.
The creme anglaise is nice
on that one. It's spot on.
We have one whole one here.
Let's see if we can get
through the middle of this.
It's not been cooked again.
And the problem with under steaming
is the lemon doesn't soften enough.
The juice doesn't come out of it,
and the sauce becomes
more sugar and butter.
I mean, the flavour's OK.
So this is going to be
an interesting judge.
Although, the shapes of the...
It's not been steamed long enough.
MATT: Prue and Paul will now rank
the puddings from worst to best.
In fifth place...
...is this one.
David, this was very under
steamed. The custard was nice.
In fourth spot, we have this one.
Massively under steamed.
It was falling through,
and the lemon was still hard.
In third place, Hermine,
the flavour was good,
but it needed two hours' steaming.
And second spot, we have
this one. Whose is this?
Mine. At least you had two
likeable looking suet puddings,
but it just needed longer to break
down the lemon and the filling.
Which means that in
first place is this one.
Laura, I wish I could say
it was wonderful,
but it really wasn't
much better than the rest.
I'm sorry. It was under-steamed,
would've been great.
Custard too thin.
And at this point, we still
normally have a round of applause
for the winner, don't we?
Well done, Laura.
Came first in a Technical.
Can you believe that?
I'm not jumping up for joy, but
I'll take that. I'm still happy.
I didn't think I'd get second.
I was hoping to be last,
I'm usually last!
Super, smashing,
great Dessert Week(!)
Not going too well!
It's still not
an unmitigated disaster
because the creme anglaise was good,
so we'll take that as a win.
MATT: Well, good luck, everybody.
We talk every week now
about the margins getting
slimmer and slimmer and slimmer.
There wasn't that much in it
in the signature,
and we've just had a Technical where
everyone pretty much did the same.
PRUE: My favourite pudding in the
whole world is a Sussex pond,
and I tell you what,
they made a complete mess of it.
But it does occur to me that
I'm 80 years old,
and steamed pudding, I grew up with
them and I absolutely love them.
And I'm 40, and I still really
like steamed pudding, too.
That's weird. Your hair, then,
is quite a lot older than you are.
All right, move on!
Laura won the Technical, and
because she had a strong Signature,
she's put herself into...
In line for Star Baker.
Yes, she has. Again.
You've got Hermine, you've got Marc,
and you've got David,
who are all sort of in the middle,
could go either way.
Peter is at the bottom,
which isn't something we've
really seen very often.
He's really got to
try his best in the Showstopper,
because he's sitting
right down at the bottom.
Good morning, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent
for your Showstopper Challenge.
Now, today, the judges would
like you each to make
a jelly art design cake.
This layered dessert needs
to have a visually spectacular
jelly art topping or coating.
At least one element of your cake
should include a baked sponge.
Noel, what jelly art would you make?
Nude sculpture of Paul Hollywood.
Oh.
What flavour would the nipples be?
Lime.
Oh. Authentic. Exactly.
You have four and a half hours.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
I didn't grow up eating jelly.
It's an Anglo-Saxon thing.
# I don't think you're
ready for this jelly! #
I'm ready for the jelly, yeah.
This is a first
for the Bake Off tent.
There's a baked element,
there's a mousse,
and then you have this jelly.
Now, I look forward to the jelly.
It's like going back to
when you were a kid again.
The setting of the jelly
is really critical.
Most of the bakers, I'm sure,
will use gelatine.
They may use agar-agar.
Gelatine is a bit of a scary beast,
because you don't know
if it's going to be enough
until you've completed it
and it's set in the fridge.
Too much, it'll be like rubber and
it won't break down in the mouth...
35 leaves of gelatine.
35 leaves of pig hide.
If you don't have your nail
and your hair growing after this,
you've got a problem.
...too little, it'll be like water.
In my last practice,
I had a bit of a collapse.
PRUE: To make the jelly art,
the bakers need to inject
liquid jelly into set jelly.
It really takes a lot of skill.
You bet I'm worried!
The stress levels in the tent
are going to be quite high.
The bakers are going to start
thinking of the final,
they're only a couple of weeks
away now.
I hope it doesn't play on their mind
too much,
because what we want are
five amazing bakes
from, actually,
five fantastic Star Bakers.
Calm, cool, collected Laura is
what you're going to see today.
Need a bit of skill, a bit of luck.
I'm hoping that they all
come together today.
Hi, Marc. Hi, Paul. Hi, Prue.
Morning, Marc.
All right, Marc, tell us all about
your jelly design cake.
OK, so I'm making, effectively,
a mousse cake
with a panna cotta insert
in the centre,
dacquoise top, and then two
layers of apple jelly on top.
Two layers of apple jelly.
Yeah, two-tier jelly.
This is going to be interesting.
As usual,
you're doing an enormous amount.
Oh, no, not again!
Yeah, but actually, the last time,
you did pull it off and managed to
get it out on time. I did, I did.
Marc's chocolate and strawberry
mousses will be sandwiched
between two layers of
ground hazelnut meringue.
His two tiers of jelly
will be flavoured with apple
and display jelly-art roses
and jasmine flowers.
So you're injecting your flowers,
are you? Yes, yeah.
And have you done this a lot before?
I wouldn't say I've done it a lot.
Well, if you want to get
through to the semifinals,
you've got to smash this one.
OK, I'll try my best.
Did that help, by the way?
No, that didn't help at all, Paul.
Marc, it's very ambitious.
Thank you.
I have some confidence
that you'll do it.
It's time to be ambitious.
It's time. Yeah, I will try my best.
PETER: So we've got a little bit
of orange and cranberry flavour.
They're mainly clear in colour
and very concentrated,
so that it doesn't affect the
texture or the look of the jelly.
All of the bakers are adding
artificial flavourings
to their main jelly features,
before setting them in the fridge.
MARC: I was originally going
to go for elderflower,
but realised it tasted
a little bit of smelly feet.
Did it? Yeah.
Well, how often have you eaten feet?
How would you know?
Well, I've already eaten one, haven't I!
Now, that's answered a lot of questions!
Getting quite firm,
which is a really good sign.
HERMINE: I'm worried about jelly
not setting enough.
That could be a big issue.
With the large elements setting,
most of the bakers are making
the coloured jelly they'll use
to make the jelly art.
This is becoming more
and more blood like, isn't it?
Vampires got the same idea.
Do you know any vampires?
Yeah, there's just one
standing next to me.
Hey, come on, that's a rumour!
You have got quite a lot of
neck exposed, though, right now!
SHE LAUGHS
They're not as set
as they normally are.
I'm actually going to
do the fish again.
Bye, little fishy.
I wouldn't do that to one at home,
promise!
Inspired by the real one in
her garden, Laura's jelly art
will be a koi pond, complete with
fish and injected aquatic plants.
It will sit atop layers of genoise
sponge, raspberry mousse
and white chocolate bavarois.
I mean, it sounds amazing.
The flavours are often good
from you, so we expect that.
What are you using to
set your jelly?
Agar-agar,
which I imported from Australia,
which I think is like, professional
use for, like, this kind of thing.
And will it be clear enough?
Yeah, it does set clear.
Is the grasshopper,
is that part of it, as well?
Who's that guy?
Oh, wow. Oh, look at him,
isn't he sweet?
He's going to be in the actual pond.
He'll be in it, as well. Yeah.
Thank you. Good luck, Laura.
Very good luck.
Going to need it!
Just wait and see
what these ones do.
While Laura needs her fish to set
before filling her pond,
Dave's opted for a paint-as-you-go
approach
to his aquatic-themed jelly art.
My jelly art is layered.
Each layer will build up
an image of, like,
a 3D perspective of a beach scene.
That goes in the fridge to set,
then I'll put another
clear layer on,
then I've got to do another
colour layer, and so forth.
MATT: Dave's jelly incarnation
of surfers' paradise Newquay
will taste of apple and guava,
riding a wave of fudge cake
and clotted cream mousse.
NOEL: Do you surf?
I try to surf. It's a thing that you
go, "Oh, I want to be good at surfing,"
and then you go,
"Oh, it's quite hard."
Yeah, you're like,
"Oh... It looked easier."
On Point Break, it looks easy.
Yeah! What a great film.
If they remade it with me and you,
you'd have to be Keanu...
You reckon?
...and I'd have to be Swayze.
Yeah, you reckon?
Yeah, not I reckon, that's a fact!
My dad's dog's called Swayze.
After Patrick Swayze?
After Patrick Swayze. Wow!
Swayze, if you're watching this,
respect!
Good luck.
While I'm waiting for it to set,
I'm going to start my cake.
For the foundations of their
jelly constructions,
most of the bakers have
chosen a type of sponge.
Just making my genoise sponge.
I think it should be pronounced
"gen-wa" but I'm from Gravesend,
so it's a "gen-oh-ese"!
Does it annoy me when
people say "gen-oh-ese"?
Well, if you're going to
speak a language,
you've got to make the effort, and
that's about all I'm going to say!
They'll be in at 170
for about 20 to 30 minutes.
It's quite a broad window
that I've given myself there.
Putting that in for 40 minutes.
I need it to be fudgy,
I don't want it to be dry, so...
But Marc's two-tiered creation
will be underpinned
with airy meringue...
This is a hazelnut dacquoise,
basically, French meringue
with folded nuts.
...while Hermine's risking possible
subsidence
by adding a cherry liqueur drizzle
to her genoise sponge.
Who can possibly hate a cake
with a bit of alcohol in it?
Her sponge needs to hold up
two mousse layers
and a domed jelly decorated
with a giant poppy flower.
She's wrapping the whole
cake in a chocolate collar
and finishing with a
white chocolate ganache.
So when we put our knife through,
is it going to hold?
Well, I hope it does.
Has it held up in practice?
I've practised them separately,
and I've never put
one on top of the other.
So it's going to be a first!
And have you done injecting jelly
before, to make flowers?
A couple of times. It is a bit
tricky cos the jelly can split.
Well, good luck. Thank you, Hermine.
Thank you. Thanks.
Going to need it!
While Hermine's gambling
with a soggy sponge...
Shall we name them
as we put them in?
...Laura's Showstopper
is taking solid shape.
Which one's got evil eyes?
Sorry, Paul. In you go!
I'm going to move on to
the strawberry mousse.
As well as the baked element
and melt-in-the-mouth jelly,
Prue and Paul want to see
a perfectly-set mousse.
PETER: I've got orange juice
and cranberry juice to reduce down,
and this is going to be
part of the base for my mousses.
Clotted cream, going in.
Gelatine will be added to this.
It just helps the mousses set,
cos we do not want another
ice cream splat.
Can't. Having nightmares about it.
It did say, "Stir in the egg yolks,"
but it's gone kind of gloopy.
Peter's also trying to
make his mousse less loose.
I'm just adding in a little bit
of cornflour to make
the custard base for the mousses
slightly thicker.
But he's the only baker whose use
of custard extends to his jelly art.
Now I'm making the panna cotta
for my moulded panna cotta shapes.
Just wanted to make sure
that I get every step right.
Can't be doing with
easy slip-ups today.
His panna cotta will
form Christmas decorations
to fit to the inside of his
clear snow globe jelly.
The extra sturdy cranberry
and orange juice mousses
will hopefully add stability
and fill the cut-out centre
of his sandwich cake.
Is there enough time to set
everything? Hopefully so.
How long did it take
to set in practice?
I don't know.
I didn't really time it completely.
You didn't time it? No.
That's useful.
We'll do it today, though. I've got
faith. All right, well, good luck.
Got faith in you. Thank you.
Good luck!
Fakey cakey bakers,
you have one hour left.
Righty ho, rinky dink, okey dokey.
I need to stay at a nice, fast lick.
The bakers need their mousses
to start setting
and their baked elements cooling...
I'd better get my prick.
I've cooked it on a lower
temperature for longer,
purposely trying to give it
a really crunchy texture.
...before they return their attention
to the star of this week's
Showstopper.
Sideways swimming fishes.
I think with the flowers above it,
it should look OK.
Here we go.
When you insert it in the cut,
as you press and draw back,
that fills it with colour.
It's a crazy technique.
LAURA: Just doing lots of petals.
It's got a ragged edge to emulate
a peony, really.
Now I'm going to do the
weirdest thing in the world,
cookie cutting panna cottas.
Oh, you bugger.
Didn't want that to happen.
These are reindeer.
They're being a little bit
tricky today.
This is quite loose.
Come on... I've got a blockage.
It's kind of baking.
Baking, but not as we know it.
Well, I'm not out of the wood, yet.
My mousse still hasn't set.
It's like a surgical operation,
isn't it?
Hopefully the jelly won't
feel any pain afterwards!
I might get some jelly flowers
put into my liver. Yeah.
Will you do it? Yeah.
I don't want to be out, though.
I want to see it all.
Wow, look at that! Yeah, getting
there. Come on, that's tremendous.
I'm going to call myself the jelly
Picasso.
I like the look of it.
I didn't know I had it in me!
I'm heating up the inside bowl here
to melt the edge of the jelly.
And then I'll be able to add in
the panna cotta figures now.
This is so annoying, look. You've
got a bit sort of hanging off,
and you don't know
where to start it.
This looks tricky. I'm so sorry.
We're just talking about opening
foil, so we're going to leave you.
Matt, you stay there until
you've worked it out.
I've got to figure this out.
This is going to be
the bottom of the jelly.
When you look through it,
you see, like,
a green background on the bottom,
and then the flowers should lift.
I just want to seal the top.
I think I'll put it
in the fridge right now.
I think I've figured it out, Laura.
I'm notorious for my mess, aren't I?
You'd be disappointed if I wasn't.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
Just need it to set.
And then I need it to release
from the bowl perfectly.
With his cake setting in the fridge,
all Dave has to do is wait.
For the rest of the bakers,
it's time to build.
You all right?
Things haven't set
as much as I'd like them to.
How do I do this?
Oh, help, help, help, help, help.
It's OK. It's OK.
Why is this so stressful?
It cracked a bit on the side.
Doing a bit of DIY here.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
I'm going to attempt to
put the jelly on the cake.
Then the jelly on the jelly.
I'm going to clip this
in some hot water.
Held too briefly in the water,
the bakers risk tearing the jelly
when they flip it over.
It all hangs on this.
It's hot, as well, this water.
Leave it too long
and they risk melting it.
That is very melty.
Too melty, probably.
Releasing now.
Come on...
That does not want to come.
Come on, release!
Doing it...
We have a wibble wobble.
Jeepers creepers.
That's not awful.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Gosh...
Bakers, your time is up.
Done it! Yeah!
Please step away from
your jelly art desserts.
I'm so happy with that.
I think it looks really cool.
Look at what happened,
I've done a jelly cake!
The good news is, I never have
to make one of those again!
After four and a half hours
of jelly artistry
and with a place in the semifinal
at stake,
the bakers have to face the judges.
Laura, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper, please?
You can see it. It reminds you of
a pond, doesn't it? Yeah.
I love the way you've put
the flowers in there,
I think they look great.
And it's got bubbles in it.
That's the koi bubbling.
Yeah. Well, it's brilliant.
I'd like to have seen the sponge
covered with something. OK.
So it looks... neater.
That jelly looks quite nice
and soft too.
Mm! The raspberry mousse is
particularly good. Thank you.
Really lovely.
It's perfect, actually. Lovely.
Every layer is excellent.
The jelly melts in the mouth,
the elderflower works really well.
Every single texture, every single
flavour is spot-on for me. Wow.
Thank you so much.
Well done. Thanks.
Smashed it, well done. Thank you.
David, I think it is
absolutely astonishing.
It is completely beautiful.
They are my colours exactly.
Yeah, Prue as a jelly design cake,
that would be it. Very clever.
I've given you a massive piece
there, Prue. David, that is so neat.
Thank you.
Your jelly is fantastic.
It's nice and light
and it melts in the mouth,
but your downfall is
the bit underneath.
Is that clotted cream mousse? Yes.
Well, you've probably put
too much gelatine in it. Yeah.
It's too stodgy.
Your sponge itself, I'm not getting
chocolate and I'm certainly
not getting fudge, though
when you eat that with that,
it feels dry. Oh, right. OK.
I wouldn't be quite so harsh.
My only quarrel is with
the mousse, which isn't as silky
soft as you expect,
but do you know what?
I think it's quite an achievement,
David, really. Cheers. Thank you.
And I think it's beautiful. Cheers.
Thank you. Well done.
Well done.
It does look phenomenal. Cheers.
It's very abstract, isn't it?
So, that's a reindeer
and that's a snowman
and that's a Christmas tree
and then it's repeated.
I don't think it looks
very like a snow globe.
Probably needed bolder colours.
When you think of a Christmas tree,
you don't think of something as pale
as that. You needed more vibrancy
to it because it's a bit pastel.
Let's have a look inside.
There's mousse right down
to the centre.
Not the easiest cake to cut.
No.
I question whether those mousses
are actually set properly yet.
They're very, very soft. OK.
I think your sponge
is slightly over baked
and you can tell by the colour.
It shouldn't be
quite as dark as that.
The flavours, though, are beautiful.
I think the main problem
is with the size,
because it's really difficult
to get a huge slice out.
And because the mousses
are only just set,
it's just like a good trifle
and I'm going to have
the other mouthful.
Thank you. Well done.
Well done, Peter.
The strawberry mousse looks curdled...
It has, yeah... and not set.
This is going to be
an interesting cut.
It's on a board as well, actually...
The jelly's on the top of a board?
Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, dear. It's slightly overdone,
this. Yeah. It's like concrete.
Oh, dear.
THEY LAUGH
Excuse me, Prue.
Is that meant to be mousse, that
chocolate? It's supposed to be, yes.
Is it?! That's more like a ganache.
Your chocolate is too hard. Yeah.
The mousse has split,
the dacquoise is over baked. Yeah.
And the jelly is...
The jelly's too rubbery.
But besides that, brilliant.
I like the design.
You're the only one, sort of,
to do a two-tier design. Yeah.
I just don't think you've organised
the whole cake as a one-piece.
I don't think the concept
was right at all. No. Right.
Beautiful. Thank you. Straight out
of a Parisian patisserie.
And I'll tell you what,
I'm a hot-stuff gardener
and that is the most perfect
Japanese poppy.
Thank you. Right.
It's absolutely gorgeous.
The raspberry, the chocolate mousse
work beautifully well together
and then you've got that
almost aromatic flavour
coming from the jelly. Fantastic.
All the layers are interesting.
The poppy top is fantastic
and you know how to make genoise
and you've made a perfect one.
So it's a real triumph. Lovely.
Well done, Hermine.
Oh, the white chocolate ganache
is delicious too. It is.
Take it away. Quickly!
Go away before we find something
to complain about. Thank you.
Well done.
Thank you.
I just can't believe it.
I mean, I was happy enough
getting a jelly cake out
and those comments... Oh, my God.
I just can't believe it.
LAUGHING: That went great,
didn't it?
Er... it could have gone better.
This is by far the week that I'm
closest to the bottom of the pile.
I'm not sure if I've done enough.
I think I have.
Wow! That was incredible.
It was good, wasn't it?
I think it was the most
amazing day, today.
What about Hermine? I think she's
done an amazing job with that.
It reminded me of looking in
the window of Fauchon in Paris.
You know, it's got that elegance
to it.
And then I thought Laura's was
really good.
It was a bit untidy round the edges,
but the cake was great,
the two mousses were good,
the topping was lovely.
I think when you look at David's,
for me, it was too halves.
The top half was amazing,
probably the best one.
But, for me, the
bottom half didn't work.
Peter's tasted really nice,
but I don't think it was the best
thing he's ever done.
You said it was too big, as well,
so it was hard to cut a slice.
When you cut a slice,
you want to be taking that around to
show people, don't you?
As opposed to, when you look at
Marc's, a chainsaw!
Because the dacquoise was just
over-baked.
Honestly, I could have stood
on that.
Poor Marc. I felt so sorry for him.
Nothing went right in that.
We're really beginning
to narrow it down now.
So we're looking at mistakes.
Now, the technical was pretty bad
for all of them,
even the person that won,
which was Laura.
And then we look at the Signature,
and it was fairly tight on that.
They all managed to produce
mini-Cheesecakes of one form
or another so, when it came
to the Showstopper
we've got to look at that
more carefully
because it's a four-and-a-half-hour
chauenge
and you can't just brush that off.
We've got to look at the Showstopper
properly.
Bakers, I have got the great job
of announcing
who is Star Baker this week.
Before I do that, I just want to say
that Showstopper was off the hook.
It really was amazing,
so well done, all of you.
Now, this week's Star Baker is...
...Hermine.
SHE EXHALES
Well done, Hermine.
Thank you.
SHE MOUTHS
Well, it falls to me, then, to tell
you who's leaving us this week.
It's someone who's
been on an incredible journey
and I know that this journey will
continue after this show.
And the person who is leaving us
this week is...
I'm so sorry, It's Marc.
It's OK.
Cheers, guys.
Give us a hug.
Cheers, mate.
Enjoy the sun! Yep.
Thank you, Prue.
I'm sorry, Marc. No, no, I knew
I'd reached my limit this week.
I'm feeling... surprisingly OK,
actually.
Gonna miss you.
Yeah, miss you too.
I mean, I came to the Bake Off
to kind of face my anxieties,
to face failure, to face all those
things that, as people,
we're quite uncomfortable
about dealing with.
I've definitely learnt a bit
more about myself,
and maybe,
from what a lot of people have said,
it's to give myself a bit more
credit, as well, which I, I don't.
Cheers, Paul. Thank you.
Marc's been great.
And actually he's been on probably
the biggest journey out of all
the bakers in the tent this year.
He started off pretty badly,
and then, as each week has
passed by, he's got better
and better and better,
and it's a shame to see him go.
Survived! Yes, survived.
I'm through to the semifinal!
I'll take that!
It's hard right now because it's,
like, fortunate for me,
but I'm going to miss Marc so much,
and it's a bit of an odd feeling.
Bittersweet, sort of happy,
but the shine has definitely been
taken off of it,
especially when you lose someone
that you're close to,
and then I think Marc
was... a real gent.
Can't believe it. I'm still seeing
myself in the tent, nervous,
about whether that jelly
will set or not.
And I can't believe they liked
that flower and the whole bake.
Aren't you a clever girl?
Hermine, her second Star Baker
in a row. She is an amazing baker.
In the past, she's done really well
because she's kept it quite safe,
but this time, she made
this amazing Japanese poppy.
It was just beautiful.
Semifinal Week next week,
and we've got four fantastic bakers.
I still cannot call who's going
to be in the final.
I don't think it's sunk in yet
that the semifinal is coming up.
It doesn't feel real.
HE EXHALES
Like, mind blown.
Next time,
the semifinal.
Don't make mistakes!
And temperatures rise again...
So warm in here.
...as the bakers meet
the challenge...
Never eaten it, never seen it.
...with a mind-bending technical.
This is like rocket science.
Who will turn it up
in the Showstopper...
We're allowed to make
a lot of noise.
...and who will be left
wooing the judges...
You have to imagine
it's Paul's face.
Ooh-ho!
...as they fight for a place in the
final of The Great British Bake Off?
How's it going?
I just don't have a logical brain.
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for
the next series of Bake Off,
visit...
Subtitles by Red Bee Media